[Music]
if someone is in the hospital and
they're really sick there's really
nothing that a clinician can do other
than give them supportive care what
we've been trying to do is develop
broad-spectrum antivirals that worked
not only against the corona viruses that
we know about today like Tsarskoe v2 the
causative agent of covin 19 but also we
want these things to have broad
application against corona viruses that
might emerge in the future a vaccine
basically is something that you take as
a preventative measure so this could be
a vaccine against SARS coronavirus -
SARS will be - the causative agent of
koban 19 if we got a vaccine then we
would be our bodies would be protected
from infection by that agent so when an
antiviral drug does it's different most
of the time you're taking these things
after you know you got sick to try and
decrease the symptoms that you might
have and prevent the development of
severe disease and you might prevent
lots of older people or people that have
underlying health conditions from going
to the hospital and ending up on a
ventilator we started working on run
desapear five or six years ago all of
the work that we did set this drug up
for immediate deployment into human
clinical trials for kovat xix I think
that's different than like someone who
might find something today right they
have to do all the work that we've been
doing for the past five years before
they can use this drug in a person or
even test it for safety
there are several human clinical trials
all over the world evaluating the
potential for different antiviral drugs
to have some effect on Kovach 19 REM des
aver chloroquine some of the HIV
protease inhibitors and some of these
other things we can basically close the
door or open the door on these things
and say this is useful this is hurtful
it's hard to know which way the wind is
going to flow